we are really in an unprecedented
situation in american politics and
really in global politics in a number of
different ways and we just
don't know who we can believe at this
point in time
about donald trump's condition when it
comes to having contracted coronavirus
and being hospitalized since
last week the president of the united
states just four weeks plus one day
that's where we are today four weeks
plus one day from a presidential
election
is in the hospital with a case of
coronavirus the same coronavirus
that he and his administration have
downplayed for months
and even ridiculed joe biden for
taking seriously and wearing a mask and
distancing and having
small crowds at his events and in
addition to this
the trump administration is not coming
clean with the seriousness of donald
trump's condition now
i am not alleging that donald trump is
deathly ill
but what is abundantly clear from the
clips i'm going to play for you later
today
is that donald trump's doctors are not
and have not been telling the truth
about donald trump's health situation
from the start
but to begin with let's cut through
all of the bs and speculation and
talking points
and just focus on what we know there are
two possibilities here either donald
trump is being given
tons of treatment despite having almost
no symptoms
merely as a precaution because he's the
president which puts him
at significant risk of side effects and
you'll hear why in a moment
or his coronavirus is much more serious
than is being admitted or as a third
possibility
which i raise not because i believe it
but because i know there will be people
who will write to me and say
you know david the third possibility is
he doesn't really have coronavirus
and it's all a sham i don't believe that
that is the case i believe the political
it's not that he wouldn't lie about it
trump would lie about anything
it's that it is of unclear benefit to
fake
having coronavirus i just don't know
that it would be
a guaranteed advantage in any way so i
don't think he would do it
what we know is that donald trump has
been in the hospital since friday
is overweight eats a terrible diet
is in his mid 70s has needed
supplemental oxygen
as of this point we believe at least two
times had a high fever at least at one
point
and is being given treatments that most
people only get when they are much more
serious why would the white house try to
hide the seriousness of trump's
coronavirus if indeed that is what they
are doing well
for optics and for public relations
purposes and in fact by the time
you hear this show today it is actually
possible that donald trump
may have already been discharged from
walter reed and be back at the white
house
i'm going to say more about that a
little bit later now
the first red flag that we saw these are
not my opinions but these are
the opinions of doctors dr john torres
explained on nbc that trump
receiving the steroid dexamethasone is a
major red flag that trump is sicker
than the white house is saying why
because dexamethasone
for coronavirus is only given when
patients have a certain degree of lung
involvement that typically would only
happen seven to ten days into the
disease
donald trump was given dexamethasone
over the weekend
just a couple of days into treatment
that is not good
number two once you read through
the nonsense of donald trump's dr sean
conley's
public statements and focus not on the
tone
but on the facts dr celine gunder
explains that trump having a fever
and an oxygen saturation level below 94
on friday
is not mild coronavirus as dr
gander explains when you have oxygen
saturation below 94
that is considered severe covid period
going further as dr gander explained on
cnn
trump was given remdessevere
remdessevere and dexamethazone
are serious medications given to
patients with severe covid
and as dr eric ding explains
dexamethasone
is typically for patients either in the
icu
or on ventilators and sometimes for
patients on oxygen who are
going in the wrong direction in advance
of possible ventilation the nih
guidelines on dexamethasone
which are on the screen for our audience
are not recommended for mild or even
moderate
cases so when we heard yesterday and the
david horo
as we heard that donald trump might be
discharged today
and that may even have happened by the
time that this show gets published
it simply doesn't line up with the facts
that we have
so if donald trump is indeed or has been
discharged today it would very likely be
for optics purposes the hypothesis would
be
again they've taken the last few days to
set up better medical facilities at the
white house
with the goal being to transfer donald
trump there
and to be able to provide care for a
more serious case
at the white house but it would be like
being at the hospital
the other possibility again because
we're working constantly with incomplete
information from dishonest actors
is that all there there is just some
bigger picture lie
that is being told here and again this
is an administration that has lied about
everything
including donald trump's health for four
years this is the skepticism
that we should be coming in with and
case in point
they have been dishonest at every single
opportunity
nobody's saying trump is going to die
nobody's saying trump is in the
icu or on a ventilator but there have
been no reasonable explanations
as to how it is that donald trump has a
mild case
it's always been mild and every day they
say he's improving
despite the fact that he's had fever has
needed oxygen at least twice
had an oxygen saturation below 94 and i
believe
in the 80s which is very serious we'll
talk about that later
received an unapproved antibody cocktail
andrum de severe
and dexamethasone is it simply because
he's the president
starting to be hard to believe this is
whatever your belief about trump is and
mine is
that he's horrible it is a stressful and
scary moment
that we are living through at this time
we're going to talk next about the lying
and the implications
and everything else i want to take a
second to tell you
about one of our sponsors s h masks
snh masks has everything you need when
it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for 19 and they're giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love
snh masks because they've donated over
60 000 masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com slash mask the link
is under this video and you can save 20
on everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david